So one explanation that people have
performed over the years for the spooky
connections and for quantum mechanics
actually in general,
is that it's an indication we live in a
multiverse and other words that there
are other domains of gals out there that
we have only very dim glimpse of quantum
mechanics says that when I measure
particle,
I get a random result and doesn't have
any explanation for that random result.
So if I flip a quantum coin,
it comes up heads or tails and I see
heads.
Now the strange thing is the mathematics
says I should see heads and tails.
So it's always been a mystery of why I
see one or the other.
The proposition is that actually that
the coin does come up,
heads entails,
but it comes up.
Heads in our universe entails another
universe.
So the idea of different universes of
parallel universes is a way to make
sense of the multiplicity of outcomes or
observed in quantum mechanics.
And people have proposed,
this would be a way to actually kind of
get rid of the non locality that the
nonlocality the spooky action at a
distance is actually our kind of
imperfect glimpse of a,
a multiverse of parallel universes and
that individually those universes all
behave completely locally,
no spooky action and I kind of actually
have a lot of sympathy for that
position.
Actually is kind of awesome to think
that might be parallel universes not
just out there but actually in here that
we can be kind of just cheek by jowl
with parallel universes all the time.
And we'd never even sent them that eve.
Any measurement we make what caused the
University of branch parallel universes
to just be conjured up all the time.
And it's kind of an amazing kind of
conception of nature.
But I've kind of gone off the idea as
much as I kind of.
I'm drawn to it initially.
And the the reason is that I think that
when you see these spooky actions and
locality in a broader context,
for instance,
in the context of other places where
they occur in nature,
not just for the particles,
but they also assumed to occur for black
holes that seemed to happen in
cosmology,
they seem to happen in the workings of
gravity.
There's a variety of contexts in which
you see spooky actions and those other
contexts are harder to explain in this
kind of parallel universe scenario,
but what they really seem to point to is
that space and time are derivative.
The real message of the spooky action is
is that space and time are not
fundamental.
Particles are rooted in that deeper
layer where space and time don't yet
exist,
and that's the way to explain them.
So the building blocks of the world may
not be tiny things.
What could these building blocks be if
they're not tiny?
Because that's kind of what we think of
as a building block of Lego is smaller
than the thing you built out of the
Legos.
They may be in what seems to us enormous
things.
Things that spent the entire universe
and they're somehow acting in concert
with one another to produce these,
these phenomena of space.